a
[Música]
hola como estan mi nombre es luis galán
yo quiero contarles una historia
nací en mi casa en pimentel por medio de
una partera antes también se podía nacer
así lo recuerdo
a los cinco años de edad mi padre me
enseñó a nadar en el mar de pimentel
también nada cuando nos íbamos de pesca
en una embarcación que él tenía
mi padre es buzo profesional
y recuerdo que en febrero en 1998
tuvimos un año golpeado por el fenómeno
del niño del norte del país
este fenómeno trajo muchas lluvias el
cual el cual causó desbordes de ríos
formación de lagos
ese mismo año lo buscaron a mi padre
para rescatar el cuerpo de una
adolescente ahogado
cuando mi padre logró rescatar el cuerpo
de estado les entregado
la familia del muchacho elevado 200
soles a cambio su trabajo
mi padre en ese momento los acepto
años más tarde cuando mi padre obtuvo un
trabajo tuvo un trabajo fijo en una
empresa
mi padre ubicó a esta familia que ayude
en el rescate en 1998 y los invitó a
almorzar
en la sobremesa mi padre sacó un sobre
con 200 soles y se lo devolvió esta
familia
explicándoles que en ese momento los
había aceptado por necesidad
esa escena quedó grabada en memoria y
fue un valor que mi padre se encargó de
marcar con esta frase
hijo no se debe lucrar con este tipo de
desgracias
aprovechándose de la necesidad de las
personas que los padecen
es entonces que la acción de ayudar es
parte de mi vida
y yo ahora que soy buzo profesional y
surfista me decidí a continuar con lo
que mi padre me inculcó a ayudar a las
personas
actualmente tengo 34 años tengo una
hermosa hija de 10 años allison con
quien comparto muchas cosas muchas
aventuras y deportes tanto como el surf
el sketch la bicicleta los patines
muchas de esas cosas que a mí me gustan
a ella también
años atrás tuve la oportunidad de vivir
un tiempo en europa
de estudiar y compartir un poco con su
gente dónde vive una realidad distinta a
la nuestra cuando volví a perú volví con
una idea una idea de ayudar
recuerdo que me reuní con una amiga y le
comenté sobre un proyecto que tenía y
las ideas que tenía para hacerlas
esta amiga también me comentó sobre unas
clases de surf como terapia para niños
autistas yo no sabía mucho sobre el
autismo pero esa idea llamó mi atención
es entonces que decidí investigar un
poquito entre internet y vi que estas
clases de surf se dan en otros países y
no solamente dan clases de surf a niños
autistas como terapia sino también a
niños con otras discapacidades
también vi lo que el mar podía hacer con
ellos no es entonces que decidí empezar
por eso dar clases de surf como terapia
para niños con habilidades diferentes
recuerda que intente hacerlo y surgieron
dos episodios que me lo impidieron pues
se vino la pandemia
y tuve una operación de emergencia por
peritonitis
en el proceso de mi recuperación me
contacte con una amiga milagritos
milagritos tienes un pequeño niño
diagnosticado con tea que es el
trastorno de espectro autista
como les comenté hace un momento yo no
sabía mucho sobre el autismo
es entonces que decidí ponerme a
investigar un poco más a investigar qué
era el tea y que era el asperger y
cuáles eran las diferencias
encontré muchas pero entre ellas
es que el tea que es el trastorno de
espectro autista tiene un coeficiente
intelectual bajo mientras el asperger
puede tener un coeficiente intelectual
alto o normal
pero ambos de esos trastornos
tienen la dificultad entre en la
comunicación la concentración
en la inclusión social
el 20 de diciembre del 2020 fue que
conocí a caler con que inició un
proyecto piloto que él es un pequeño
niño de 5 años diagnosticado con tea
antes de conocer a cal él
yo había hablado un poquito con su mamá
y le había preguntado qué cosas le
gustaba caler como su comida favorita su
color favorito y su dibujo animado
favorito y en este caso en el nombre de
rain
el día que llegó cal él por su clase de
surf llegó súper tímido escondiéndose
detrás de su mamá
yo lo saludé y para llamar su atención
le hablé sobre el hombre araña pues le
comenté le dije cullen tú sabes que el
hombre araña surfea cuando vi que llame
su atención
enseguida le dije cullen te gustaría
ponerse un traje como el del hombre
araña y él corrió muy rápido en mí para
poner el traje
igual que el del hombre hay que irnos a
surfear
desde ese entonces que él es uno de mis
alumnos en fundación astro perú
el avance que he tenido que leer a
través de las clases de surf como
terapia son totalmente increíbles pues
si antes le costaba darse la mano ahora
no sólo lo hace sino que también
interactúan entre sí
juegan entre ellos socializan un poco
más
hace el trabajo en equipo hoy en día
tenemos más de 50 alumnos en fundación
hasta perú
y créanme la energía la buena vibra lo
que nos transmite en cada de esos niños
cada uno de esos niños a nosotros los
instructores es algo inexplicable
creo que el mayor premio que hemos
recibido de ellos es su sonrisa su
felicidad
yo soy padre
y sé lo que se siente cuando cuando le
sucede a alguno de nuestros hijos cuando
se enferman cuando les pasa algo esa
misma sensación en la que percibo cuando
viene una familia y me da la confianza
de yo poder
enseñarle a sus hijos
más que el hecho de fundar algo es el
hecho de saber que lo que amo como el
mar y el surf ayuda a muchas personas
pienso que haber vivido en pimentel
frente al mar toda mi vida me ha ayudado
mucho de niño recuerdo cuando bajaba a
la playa
y era muy feliz
de jugar de correr de bañarme se me
olvida todo y simplemente era el niño
más feliz del mundo
pienso ahora
que estos niños tanto como canela
nicolás o michelito
[Música]
puede tener un mundo mejor y sus
familias son un poco más felices pese a
las dificultades que han de seguir
afrontando
recuerda
uno nunca sabe qué problema tiene el
otro pero mientras podamos tener una
mano estoy seguro de que habremos
cambiado la vida de esa persona y
también la nuestra
gracias
[Música]